[Applause]
good evening everybody what a treat to
see all of you here what a wonderful
turn turnout we're very very pleased
that you are here with us and that you
will be hearing seen a wonderful program
tonight this is the third event in this
year's Leon Panetta lecture series this
season we've been discussing as you know
the American Dream tonight our speakers
will focus on the presidency and the
role of leadership and how that
influences the American Dream our
greatest presidents were dedicated to
giving all Americans the opportunity for
a better life from Franklin Roosevelt's
New Deal to Ronald Reagan's shining city
on a hill presidents have struggled to
make sure that all Americans have a
chance to achieve the American dream a
president's leadership on issues from
war to the economy from education to
jobs from health care to conservation
and others determines whether we have
the opportunity to succeed at the same
time we also understand that presidents
are human and make mistakes and we've
paid for those mistakes the strength of
the modern presidency has challenged as
never before in our history with deep
partisan divide and dysfunction that
makes it difficult to govern the failure
of Washington to deal with critical
issues facing Americans is what in part
led to the election of President Trump
he has brought a very different style of
leadership to the presidency he has
challenged many of the traditional norms
of that office he's criticized our
system of checks and balances and taken
executive action to reverse past
policies and he communicates his views
to the American people by tweeting his
supporters believe that he
doing exactly what he was elected to do
change Washington his opponents believe
he governs by chaos who is right and how
will all of this affect the American
Dream the presidency is one of the most
powerful institutions in the world but
so is our Constitution and so is our
system of checks and balances tonight
we the people have the opportunity to
freely debate and discuss all those
issues the freedom to do that in our
democratic society gives us the impetus
to know that we as citizens are
responsible for protecting the American
Dream tonight Leon will discuss these
issues with our guests too who have
spent their careers observing the
presidency and one who served President
Trump has his first chief of staff our
first guest is one of the most famous
political investigative reporters in
America a two-time Pulitzer Prize winner
he is a keen observer of the inner
workings of government of politics and
the role of leadership he is an
associate editor of the Washington Post
where he has worked since 1971 he has
shared in two Pulitzer Prizes first for
the coverage of the Watergate scandal
with Carl Bernstein and second as the
lead reporter for coverage of the 9/11
terrorist attacks called the best pure
reporter of his generation perhaps ever
by the Weekly Standard he has authored
or co-authored more national
best-selling non-fiction books than any
other contemporary American writer his
bestseller the price of politics was
released in 2012 published in 2015 his
most recent book the last of the
presidents
provides the last pieces of the complex
story of the Nixon administration and
its legacy he received his BA from Yale
University and please welcome Bob
Woodward
[Music]
laughter
[Music]
our second guest is also one of the most
influential journalists in American
history he has spent 40 years reporting
on the inner workings of government and
politics and the hidden stories of
Washington and its leaders
he began his journalism career at age 16
as a copy boy for the Washington evening
star and then became a reporter at 19 in
the early 70s he broke the Watergate
story for the Washington Post and was
awarded the Pulitzer Prize in
recognition since then he has continued
to investigate and write about the use
and abuse of political media financial
cultural and spiritual power the author
of five best-selling books his recent
work is the national bestseller a woman
in charge the life of Hillary Rodham
Clinton acclaimed as the definitive
biography of it's subject that was
published in 2007 his next book a memoir
of his family's experience in the
McCarthy era is titled loyalties a sons
memoir he attended the University of
Maryland so please welcome Carl
Bernstein
welcome
our final guest is the former White
House chief of staff to President Trump
and the longest-serving chairman of the
Republican National Committee in recent
history he worked his way up through the
ranks of the Republican Party of
Wisconsin as first congressional
district chairman state party treasurer
invite first Vice Chair and was
eventually named state party chairman in
2007 in 2009 he served as general
counsel to the Republican National
Committee he assumed the chairmanship of
the RNC in 2011 and oversaw a dramatic
turnaround of the GOP he left the RNC is
one of the most successful chairmen of
either political party in American
history he was named White House chief
of staff shortly after president Trump's
historic 2016 victory and left the
administration in the summer of 2017 he
has a BA from the University of
Wisconsin and a JD from the University
of Miami
please welcome Reince Priebus
and of course moderating our discussion
is the man who created this lecture
series more than 20 years ago he has
served in public life under nine
American presidents was chief of staff
to one president and CIA director and
Secretary of Defense to another he knows
the importance of good leadership
so please welcome Secretary Leon Panetta
[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
got a hell of a crowd you know you're in
for a great show
we we welcome you to the third form of
the Panetta lecture series our theme as
you know is the American dream alive and
well we've talked about impasse forms
about the economy we've talked about
national security and in our last forum
we'll talk about technology but tonight
we focus on the presidency why
because the presidency happens to affect
the fate of our country and whether or
not people in this country you're going
to be able to succeed and enjoy the
American dream
presidents make the decisions about
whether or not we go to war whether
young men and women are put in harm's
way presidents make the decision about
how to deal with economic crisis
presidents make the decision about
whether or not they're going to support
security for American citizens
that's how Social Security came into
existence and Medicare funds for
education housing issues issues related
to jobs a highway program to develop
those jobs all of that is impacted by
the presidency at the same time
presidents are human and they make
mistakes and we paid the price for those
mistakes and so it's important for us
this evening to look at what are the
qualities of the president who succeeds
who's good who's good for the country
what about those that are not so good
what about our system of checks and
balances can it deal with checking the
power of the presidency these and so
many other questions are we that we will
discuss tonight with this very
distinguished panel and let me let me
begin with the panel with the question
that I think is important the kind of
establish a baseline on the presidency
putting president Trump aside for the
moment we've all observed presidents
talk to presidents or as writes and I
did we were chiefs of staff to the
president I want you to comment on in
your lifetime who was the best president
and who was the worst and why
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no problem simple question easy then the
surprise I think for a president that I
really thought did a great job in our
lifetimes with Gerald Ford Nixon's
successor and I learned that in a began
really 30 days after Nixon resigned Ford
had been vice president and he was
president and Ford went on television on
a Sunday morning announcing he was
giving Nixon a full pardon for Watergate
and that III really think Ford hoped he
could go on early on that Sunday morning
and no one would notice but it was
widely noticed but not by me I was
asleep and Carl called me and Carl truly
has the ability to say what occurred in
the fewest words with the most drama and
say yeah have you heard no I'm sleepy
said well the son of a [ __ ] pardoned us
on November
[Applause]
well I historic odor ring on and I was
able to figure out what had happened and
instantly I thought in Carl agreed this
is perfect this is the final corrupt act
of Watergate that Nixon gets a free run
and a pardon 40 people go to jail and
thought that for a long time
particularly two years later when Ford
ran against Jimmy Carter and lost
essentially because of the suspicions of
the pardon that there was some sort of
deal 25 years later and one of my books
shadowed the legacy of Watergate and
five presidents I went back to
re-examine the pardon call Jerry Ford up
had never met him never interviewed him
and said I want to relook at the pardon
and thought he would say no and Gerald
Ford turned out to be one of the most
open honest direct people I'd ever
encountered so I had the luxury of time
to full-time assistants I read every all
the memoirs interviewed everyone who is
alive and went to see Ford many times he
had a home in Colorado of Maine home in
Rancho Mirage California and just you
know well what happened and I remember
the last interview with Ford in his
little house in Rancho Mirage right off
Golf Course and I just said why did you
pardon Nixon hey so do you keep asking
that question and I said well I don't
think you've answered fully and then he
said you're right
I have not answered it fully I'll tell
you what happened I haven't even told
Betty and so and so he goes through and
he said God let me take you to the
moment I've been president 30 days my
god it was awful it was
much distrust no one would believe
anything all the news was about what's
going to happen to Nixon the Soviet
Union did the Cold War was on the
economy was in trouble the special
prosecutor had sent him a letter saying
Nixon is a private citizens going to be
investigated because of the tapes note
that doubt indicted convicted will maybe
go to jail so Ford says who were going
to have two or three more years of
Watergate and I will never forget him
saying I needed my own presidency we had
to move beyond Nixon and so I preempted
the process and then Al Haig came to me
and offered a deal the week before how
Haig being the chief of staff for Nixon
and and he said I rejected that deal
because it would have been corrupt Nick
because Haig said okay you guarantee
you'll pardon xyn and he will resign you
get the presidency and Ford said you
know look I knew I was going to be
President in any ways anybody a deal you
get to be President I know that's coming
and I'm supposed to pardon Nixon they
said I rejected that that was corrupt
and I said but I said but you did
pardoned Nixon and he said but here's
why because of this situation for the
country I had to think about I was I was
in charge I had to I'd you know this is
a job of stewardship and I realized we
that you know this idea he needed his
own president country had to move on he
could do one thing and so he said this
is how I assess the national interest
and he did it and so in the book I said
you know actually instead of this being
corrupt it was gutsy and they awarded
him the kennedy prize profiles in
courage from JFK's book
and I remember watching that and that
made my god here I was sure Ford had
done the most corrupt thing in the world
and then it under examination neutrally
25 years later what looks corrupt turns
out to be courage yeah interesting and I
mean what what a humiliating humbling
experience to be so sure and so we sit
now and we talked about your former boss
Trump and everyone sure where this is
going and what it means and so forth and
as a reporter I look at this and I say
we do not know so much like mr.
secretary here my most of my family
isn't from the United States so if ever
wonder how did I get a name like Reince
Priebus like who names their kids rights
that's what happens when a Greek and a
german get married
cultural disaster have you ever seen my
Big Fat Greek Wedding that's in my life
so the fighting starts at 7:00 in the
morning and it ends you know midnight
and everything's and everyone's business
so but my my upbringing like all of our
upbringing is a huge part of our life
and so the person I looked up to the
most in my life and the person that I
would follow around the house everywhere
and everything he said was when my pappu
my grandfather from Greece would come to
Wisconsin and it wasn't like you know
when our relatives come for a long
weekend when the Greeks come it's a
couple months and they're living there
but I remember take taking him taking
the letter P off the shelf from the
world books remember those I need to sit
there all day and read these world books
and I would sit next to him now he had a
little Johnnie Walker next to him well
he was really but he had read the letter
he read for presidents from the letter P
and it didn't matter who he was talking
about it could be FDR it could be
Kennedy it can be you know Andrew
Jackson Jimmy Carter every single one of
these guys was great oh he was great
Reagan was the best and what I took from
that is that the person I looked up to
the most in my life loved everything
about this country but he wasn't from
here every little crumb about what I
love is what you have and I don't and so
I don't I haven't sat through no offense
as many American presence of you all
have the advantage of being somebody
asked us once what was Calvin Coolidge
I was taking more rambling but when I
look at presidents in in and the former
chief of staff gave me a reprieve
because he took president Trump off the
table
I look at who's inspiring this country
and look at Ronald Reagan and the
feeling that he gave Americans across
this country Republicans Democrats not
all but a lot of people inspired by the
American Dream about something bigger
and beyond legislation but how we feel
as Americans and making people proud
again I think that was Ronald Reagan you
know I don't remember a lot about Jimmy
Carter other than what I read and
obviously I would put him more at the
bottom of the list from the folks I grew
up in he seems like a good man but
Ronald Reagan captures the upbringing of
a person that lived in the place that I
lived and was looking for something to
be inspired by and that's really what
got me involved okay so X we've got Ford
Nixon you didn't mention it but I assume
Nixon Avada yeah you've got something
right okay all right we've got Reagan
and Carter Carl it's up to you well
again Nixon is at the bottom because he
was a criminal president he was criminal
president from the day he took office
until the day he left and he's unique in
our history in that regard and and what
your question goes to really is a
commitment by the President of the
United States to the common good to the
national interest and so my first
president I covered was Kennedy and and
all presidents have their successes
their failures but the two that stand
out in retrospect in terms of a
commitment to the common good putting
the interests of the country over their
own interests without huge character
flaws that have brought them low
I go to Gerald Ford
for the reasons that that bob has
enumerated he he did that pardon knowing
it would probably cost him the
presidency when he ran for re-election
he was willing to put the national
interest above his own interest and
being re-elected to the presidency
knowing he probably would lose this as a
result of others but also I think we
have to look at Barack Obama won in
terms of personal rectitude which he
displayed throughout his presidency
whatever his failings in terms of policy
of putting this act of healthcare before
something else partisanship whatever we
look at though I think the idea of the
common good in the national interest and
we have to look at Obama in terms of
really saving American capitalism saving
us from a depression in the first months
and days of his presidency when the
Republican opposition rather than
looking toward the common good was
committed to really undermining the
incoming president of the United States
not a single Republican went to the same
solution and embraced Obama's solution
of dealing with the financial crisis
Obama was advised by Republicans who he
inherited from the previous
administration but those acts you might
disagree with the bailout the size of
the bailout what one company was given
that this bank should have been put into
receivership or maybe it shouldn't but
he really saved our system and probably
saved the world truth from a real
depression that would have been ongoing
he did it despite the fact that he was
being accused of all kinds of things
that and that the other way would have
been a kind of austerity approach that
failed elsewhere
in the world and I and I think his
steadfastness there in I'm gonna do the
right thing and I think that's that's
the basic question which presidents go
what is the right thing for the people
of this country for the greatest good
the national interest and so I think
those are two examples so right you
can't avoid this we we have to now look
at Trump and you you know the president
better than I think all of us by virtue
of having served him in the campaign and
then served him as chief of staff you're
quoted as saying about your time in the
White House that you can take everything
you've heard and multiply it by 50 what
was it like what how identify for us
what what his strengths are and what his
weaknesses are as you saw well what I
was describing was the job of chief of
chief of staff and you know obviously
when a four-star combat marine and John
Kelly says it's the hardest job I've
ever had in my life it goes to tell you
that being chief of staff is not easy
and you know that you've been there but
also you know when President Trump is is
different he's a more complicated he's
someone who's never run for office
before he wants to be perfect he wants
to be perfect on little things middle
things big things
he's like many successful people and
patient but I would say to people who I
think get a Miss read in the media and
take it from me I mean I had listened I
had resigned the day before at a great
talk with the president multiple times
but I too walked down those steps read a
tweet that I was being replaced by John
Kelly so I'm coming to you as someone
who is not here to spin I think that
this is a president who made it very
clear who he was and how he was going to
govern when he campaigned people were in
this country in most of the country
we're tired of being
- they were tired of all the phony
promises they were tired of phony they
were tired of plastic and they wanted
someone that was going to be the bit of
biggest middle finger but they could
find to tell people in Washington to go
take a hike and the president has
fulfilled and if you're Republicans and
I know that I'm in a part of the country
where maybe there's not a lot of them
here maybe there is no therefore if
you're a Republican yeah if you're a
Republican you love the results of what
this president has done you like the
fact that Isis is Isis is on the run you
love the fact that for every new
regulation 22 have been eliminated you
like the fact that this president is on
his way of appointing more conservative
judges or any judges than any president
in modern history tax cut from 35 down
to 21 on the corporate business side my
point is this will probably spend some
time tonight talking about what the
media talks about which is what they say
is the drama and the chaos what I would
suggest to you is to avoid concentrating
on meaningless drama and focus in on the
results because you're not look I got
rolled up in some of that the people say
well how do you have such a good
attitude of because my you know that
drama doesn't matter to American history
what matters to American history is the
success or failures of this president
and if you're Democrat you hate it if
you're Republican you love it but the
fact is nuts-and-bolts promises that he
made to the American people he's
delivering let me talk about the modern
presidency there's a great article in
the Atlantic by John Dickerson that
talks about the modern presidency is an
impossible job
this is a quote no man or woman can
possibly represent the varied and
competing interests of 327 million
citizens perform the ever-expanding
duties of the office the most powerful
man in the world is powerless to achieve
many of his goals for today and enormous
bureaucracy is the modern presidency
broken and is Trump in some ways a
consequence of that no I I think that's
the wrong way to look at it I think a
president can succeed I think it's all
about leadership and you know if you go
for a job interview they'll and they'll
say ok you're here for this job what's
the definition of the job well what's
the definition of the job of president
and having thought about it through
eight presidents now working on a book
on Trump it for me the job of the
president is that role of stewardship
but it's also figuring out what the next
stage of good is for a majority of
people in the country real majority not
just a base not just one party not just
a bunch of interest groups because
things can be done through the
presidency and by the president that
really make a difference in people's
lives and then the president has to say
this is what it is ok what's the
strategy to get there it may take years
to get there but that's the job of the
president and it is a shame when it gets
misdirected or you know whether some of
Ryan says you know that things seem
trivial and so forth but what it I find
missing in the Trump presidency there
was the campaign and there's you know
he's going to do this
he's gonna do that where are we going I
am the 1960s I served in the Navy and I
was on a ship and the executive officer
number two I would I spent a lot of time
in his office because I was a
troublemaker and then decayed and he had
he had never heard you call renegades
yes and he had a plaque glued to his
desk and I never will forget it because
I saw it many times and it was he who
does not know to which port he is
sailing has no favorable wind and that's
true there are winds out there that are
favorable unfavorable and they can get
you but you need to know the port to
which you were sailing and I do not find
enough evidence in the public discourse
from the President or out of Washington
from Democrats where are we going what's
this all about what are we trying to
accomplish I think the lack of clarity
hurts the president hurts the country
and hurts all of us and I think it I
think it is a tragedy that there's not
some mechanism I mean did you ever try
to figure out into which port from
Donald Trump was sailing I guess I I
respectfully disagree I mean I think if
you look at the first year you have you
you have the appointment and the
nomination of Neel Gorsuch which have a
profound effect in the Supreme Court at
the same time we tackled the health care
bill unsuccessfully and then we moved
into tax reform eventually passing the
first tax reform since 1986 and
obviously moving into matters related to
North Korea
Isis Syria I think that there is clarity
but I'm sorry but it matters involving
North Korea there was all this you know
fire and fury where we have Trump saying
is a big trend now turned out that the
critics have the mmm not gonna say for
sure but the critics have to be there
they're on the short end of that stick
in the fact this many people who like
who are used to the conventional method
of Washington decision-making and people
like me too
are people that were uncomfortable with
how the president approached North Korea
but like so many issues that he pushes
back on immediately right off the bat
whether it be trade whether you know
whether it be Afghanistan whether it be
Syria and North Korea he pushed in and
put all the ships on the table people
all cried about it I've been a strong
right and it turns out that unlike all
the predecessors before Trump here we
are potentially on the verge of
something dramatic and world-changing
when it comes to North Korea so plug a
leak right I'll take this agenda for
another two and a half years and and run
on it in 2012 right so you at you and I
talked about this earlier but and I
think there's a lot of truth to it this
president operates with with chaos in
taking these kind of steps that he takes
but then I think he uses the chaos as
leverage is that that's not a percent
right what President Trump made it very
clear in the art of the deal when he
talked about his style of management his
style of management is not the same old
process were used to what he said in the
art of the deal is he likes to keep
things loose he doesn't want to be
overbooked and he wants to come to the
office and see what develops but the
president does is he puts people around
him
that don't agree with each other on a
whole lot and you read about it every
day so if we're talking about Tradehill
have the guy from Goldman Sachs Wilbur
Ross Reince Priebus Steve ban and all
these people that are of you know
different species I mean natural
predators and they'll stand there in
front of the aptly named resolute desk
in front of the president and they will
have it out and the president like a law
school professor will sit back and watch
and the press will talk about the fact
that this guy said that Reince was this
and this one was over here and he's but
thrown out of the office and these
people were arguing and I'll have the
camera in the Oval Office with people
scream at each other but the president
then uses that information and makes a
decision so what I would challenge
people people who don't even like the
president focus on the results and
forget about the process because it's a
different problem but in the process I'm
sorry I've about North Korea I thought
last year we were on the verge of war
and part of that came from what the
president said where the guy was
launching a missile every two-and-a-half
hours yes over Japan exactly but now
we're on the peace track and I just want
to have it both ways
you don't want North Korea to to make
provocative to make provocative moves
you want the president to be a leader
but then he is a leader and then we get
to a place where now North Korea and
South Korea are shaking hands and
hugging and now we're critical the
president because where's the port about
this discussion and first it first of
all we see this Donald Trump a is the
legitimate President of the United
States period end of paragraph second of
all he had a much better reading of the
country than his Democratic opponent did
he read the country brilliantly and ran
a campaign with a kind of brilliance
that it was soo a generous unlike
anything that we've ever seen and
through his own kind of smarts he won
won the presidency
and I think we need to accept that
thirdly that the consistent hallmark of
Donald Trump in public life and of his
presidency his lying and it's that we've
never had a president of the United
States who has lied with the kind of
consistency with it being a basic
methodology of his approach to the
American people with his approach to
governance and it is essential to who he
is from every evidence we have I'm not
talking about being an opinion that
opinionated editorial writer here it is
demonstrable reparatory Oh fact that we
are looking at a body of lies told by
the President of the United States with
a kind of regularity that is so
troublesome that everybody
Republican Democrat whether they agree
with the results or not needs to be
concerned about because we need real
leadership that includes a degree of
moral leadership a degree of ethical
leadership
[Music]
and indeed when other presidents have
gone to lying as a in terms of really
being essential to some of their acts
Nixon who again was a criminal president
from day one until the day he left
office he didn't lie every day but but
in when he did lie in Watergate it was
the end of him but nonetheless this is
something new in the history of the
presidency and it's something I believe
it has to be part of our discussion here
both in terms of journalism in terms of
the office in terms of the president let
me I think I think I just want to say
one thing though I mean on the issues
that he promised the American people I
feel like he's fulfilling these promises
he said he was gonna knock the hell out
of Isis and he is he said he's gonna
take his justices and his judges from a
list of these conservative judges and he
is he said he's gonna pass tax reform
and he did I mean I think the president
is a litigator I do think he takes the
facts from a scenario and uses those
facts to his advantage I do think that
but
okay there's a white thing I think
you're I think you're all there hissing
and booing over in material garbage let
let it lay let me move on bully the
bully pulpit presidents in the past of
you speeches have used fireside chats
have used Oval Office addresses in order
to speak to the American people
these are usually prepared they're well
coordinated they're talking points this
is a president who used tweeting we are
in the era of social media and you know
he basically wants to communicate the
way he wants to communicate is this what
future presidents are going to be doing
in order to communicate with the
American people Carl I have no idea I
think the use of unconventional media
it's probably very likely the
president's will continue to do that I
am one who particularly as a reporter
I'm really grateful that Trump tweets
with the frequency that he does but I
also think that the tweets are Trump at
his most truthful that we see in the
tweets where his mind really is and if
you go back and you sort through the
tweets it really is a road map of of the
president's mind it tells us a lot about
what concerns him about where his
abilities lie and don't lie and I think
it's the best indication that we have of
how to judge him as a person as a
president and where he's going
who he believes in what he's
contemptuous of and and we're lucky that
that is his method of communicating
because otherwise we'd know damn near
okay but there are contradictions in the
tweets yeah lined them all up it will be
one way this way but in terms of
listening to rinses point I'm trying to
think this through there may be some
strategy in this and it was to non-trump
spark two years ago young reporter at
the post Bob Kosta who you know and I
interviewed Trump he was right on the
verge of winning the Republican
nomination and it was in his hotel on
Pennsylvania Avenue undergoing Rena
renovation and Kosta and I said okay now
you know he's going to win the
Republican nomination but he probably
won't be President so let's think about
the things we can ask him that will
address what's inside what's driving
here so we spent some time and one of
the very interesting interview in
retrospect but the most important moment
was I believe we asked we said Oh
President Obama still president at this
point I had talked about power and the
presidency ultimately is about power and
Obama had said in his first inaugural
that power comes to the United States
from its restraint and humility and you
could just see Trump you know those
words I wish there were a video yeah
because he was kind of and then we that
Obama just said real power was quoting
Obama to trump real power comes from not
using violence and then Trump and I
swear
it was almost Shakespearean it was
almost like Hamlet turning to the
audience and you know one of those
asides here's what I really think and
Trump said quote real power
is I don't even like to use the word but
real power is feel and I going back and
thought about that in the context of you
know what he does he scares people he
scared the hell out of Kim jong-un and
you look at it and you follow this and
the North Korean leader is now gonna
meet now whether that's a strategy of
mobilizing fear I don't know but you
start trying to say does that make sense
to you well maybe it's out of it so what
do it than that - there is part of the
equation and there's all kinds of pieces
on the chessboard that are moving he
also has an incredible ability and you
talked about this before of engaging in
people in one-on-one settings that you
can't fully appreciate watching the news
every night he is incredibly gracious
with people meaning I don't know how to
describe it but there are some people
you know when they have an ability to
meet people one-on-one and become
instantaneously tight yeah I saw that
with your president Bob a Clinton was
good like that I saw that with President
Xi and he uses these relationships and
they're genuine to form these bonds that
are necessary in order to get this
situation in North Dakota under control
without that close relationship that if
it was phony and below North Korea North
Korea
but he if that relationship wasn't real
with President Xi it we just wouldn't be
here right now so there is a genuine
god-given skill there what that I don't
think the media gives the press okay let
me ask you is your chief of staff yeah
and you've got a president who's
tweeting at five o'clock in the morning
I mean if if if I served a president
that did that it would drive me crazy
and I mean how can you deal with we're
in Steve for two years during the
campaign right and so I was the guy that
was constantly calling the the
soon-to-be president say you can't do
this don't tweet that this is the way
you do it this is the way you don't do
it and he did it the way he wanted to do
it and he became president which which
you know if you look at President Trump
you cannot deny the fact that he's a man
who has achieved incredible success as
people sneer and year but wait a minute
he is a billionaire he is president
United States okay he's got more money
than we all do okay
and he is president of the United States
and okay well apparently some people
don't agree with you and he's done it
while people like me we're telling him
don't do this don't do that and it turns
out that he did it and he won and an
election day he was at 37% and he won
and so it's harder to get to your
question when you're a chief of staff
six months later to say don't do this
don't do that when he's heard it all
before and those people in his mind were
wrong and he was right and he was
affirmed by the American people okay
we're at the halfway point but I really
want you to address this issue before we
go into the questions which is the role
of the press since both of you are in
the press both of you really used the
press to check the power of the
presidency and yet you know presidents
have always had a rough relationships
with the president with the press but
it's pretty bad right now
and we saw it over this last weekend at
the Correspondents Dinner
you know comedian got up and attacked
Trump Trump was in MA in Michigan
attacking the press before you know his
crowd and so there there's a lot of
questions about what is the what is the
role of the press today has the press
lost his credibility or is it still an
effective check in our system well I I I
think we're in danger of losing their
credibility and we've lost credibility
with lots of people and the criticism
that Trump has offered very aggressively
I mean macaca forty five years ago and
covering Watergate we have Carl was 11
years old I was 12
we were kids and there was the leader of
the free world or a spokesman Ron
Ziegler up there saying our stories are
full of lies that we are character
assassins something that I think Trump
has not yet called the media and the
message to us from our editors the great
Ben Bradley and others was keep doing
the work don't get consumed with trying
to fight and so we and I look at some of
the coverage I think the coverage by the
New York Times and the Post The Wall
Street Journal you aggregated it I mean
it's been very good
very some mistakes and so forth but
Trump is such has such an ability to set
people off and he's done this to the
press and people have taken the bait and
there is too much people have become I
have lost their equilibrium in the media
and I think you have to take the Ben
Bradley rule you know he always said
here's what you do know nose down ass up
moving slowly it's just a quick comment
on the role of the press yeah where are
we today
well Trump has tried to make the issue
of his presidency and Nixon tried to do
the same as Bob was indicated the
conduct of the press instead of the
conduct of the President of the United
States and he's had even more success
and Nixon was successful at it for a
good while in the early stages of
Watergate people were believing Nixon
not what we were writing in the
Washington Post for a long time
this is a different time in America
we're really in a state of a kind of
cold civil war in this country today
Donald Trump didn't cause it
he's evolutionary in terms of it was
perhaps inevitable that we were gonna be
at a place like this with a president
who appeals to part of that cold Civil
War and indeed tries to stoke the cold
Civil War by appealing to a base rather
than trying to appeal to a United vision
of the country that most citizens can
appreciate that that's his methodology
and he wants us to be he's called us the
enemy of the people as Joseph Stalin
once used use the phrase it's
extraordinary and we are faced and Bob
is is really right here the reporting by
the New York Times The Washington Post
The Wall Street Journal Selma CNN's
reporting I believe is the best
reporting on the American presidency on
a daily basis that I have seen since I
went to work
[Applause]
there also is the fact that we need as
ben bradlee appreciated we also need a
kind of reporting where reporters step
back take a month two months three
months on a story and look at the
presidency with that kind of distance
and care and you're not on a daily daily
deadline but also that we have ventured
sometimes too far in the end of the
pejorative and it comes partly because
the quote press does something now that
it didn't traditionally at the time of
Watergate and and we've seen
increasingly in the last twenty years
and that is reporters myself included
Bob included we go on television and
talk about what is going on beyond what
we write online or in the paper or even
in our books that's something new and in
the process of that I think we've
invited some trouble for ourselves by
being sometimes too pejorative but it's
particularly difficult and this is not
an excuse because there is so much lying
by this President of the United States
so much of what the press has been doing
is to repertory early point out those
lies those untruths to parse what the
president and it didn't start
incidentally with this president but to
parse what is truthful what is not and
in the process of that I think has
conveyed a kind of self-righteousness
that has led toward some undermining of
our credibility and has been perhaps
interpreted as or mistakenly interpreted
or not as adversary adversarial without
any relationship to trying to get to the
truth when I would say the purpose of it
is to try to get to the truth
long-winded answer
right just hold on a second let me get
this done because uh you know I did
we've got to recognize our question
review team and the people who select
the questions I'll ask you to hold your
applause while I give you their names
chelsea Adame who's a local news editor
for Salinas California Fran Gaver who's
our veteran question review team member
David Kellogg managing editor of the
Monterey Herald and Doug McKnight who's
a reporter of kzu radio if you would
thank them for the work that they do we
had a great turnout of students we had
over 600 students today at our session
with the streaker
[Music]
and some great questions it was it was a
wonderful turnout we could not do it
without your support so Sylvia I and the
Panetta Institute board of directors are
very grateful for the sponsorship that
allows these students high schools
colleges universities military
installations from throughout the
Central Coast to be able to participate
so please thank those sponsors
all right I'm just gonna say that and
move quickly but and I think these
gentlemen here are American legends and
they view the press in a way that what I
dealt with in the West Wing and what I
dealt with for six years at the RNC was
many times reporting based on anonymous
sources reporting based on you know
three people said that this person said
that the president was an idiot and
we're running with it what do you have
to say about it
and it's a bunch of inconsequential
garbage BS and most stories that we have
to deal with are like that now granted
there are real stories that need to be
covered that are serious and I
understand that and I and I'm not
actually saying that most of the
reporters that work day in and day out
and in the West Wing
are good decent people I don't think
that they're making up quotes I don't
think that it's out of thin air but I do
think that there are troublemakers and
nefarious people that if you get two or
three of them granted you can create a
story and you can pop it up on a website
and you can get a lot of clicks but I
don't what I think is missing a lot of
times in the press is the discernment to
decide whether a particular story a very
little value is worth the time and in
the end the filth that it creates and so
I don't see the discernment I see
massive competition
I see clickbait I see headlines that
don't match the stories beneath and that
to me is where most of our fights occur
oh okay by the way the presses the
presses of polling with the public is
below Congress right now so obviously
something's wrong and the American
people feel that the press is not being
honest with them when they do things
like they did on Saturday night they
just make President Trump the winner
again oh yes that's quickly but but
years
[Applause]
there's partial truth than what you say
I think that's true
and of course you contradicted the
president who says the press makes up
things all the time you said they said
they don't know those people in the West
Wing
I don't believe they make it up in thin
air but I have been and I'm not going to
go through it right now but I have been
in situations where matters that are
reported by the press are not as they
have appear that Andrew McCabe stories
the classic yes I will repeat it but but
yours it's a total classic
snow job and they knew it right but
here's the interesting thing there needs
to be self-examination in introspection
on the part of the press we need to
produce a better product how do you
produce a better product time against
the problem that we used to have at the
post little signs that we put on above
the screen and somebody's computer and
it was FAA and that didn't mean Federal
Aviation Administration it meant focus
act aggressively and we've got to focus
we've got to act aggressively we've got
to be fair we've got to improve the
product and if we don't anybody you know
go tell people who've been in businesses
where they've had a product that's not
selling very well and they are not in
business anymore okay no I
let me ask you please shut him up for 46
years old state that story you know it's
a good story
what word is Bernstein okay yeah you
were involved in Watergate of what are
the differences and similarities between
Watergate and the Russian investigation
and will they will it end the same way
first of all we don't know where the
Russian investigation is going to go
what we do know is there has been a
cover-up that the president has
attempted to cover up and been
untruthful about many elements of what
we have seen and what has been reported
that he has tried at various turns to
undermine lawful investigations that
doesn't mean he is committed legal
obstruction of justice that remains to
be seen there's a big story that the New
York Times has put out about an hour ago
with the 48 questions that Muller wants
to ask the President of the United
States it's an interesting list that
that gives some indication that did
Muller is very much looking into
questions of quote collusion that that
matter has not by any means been put to
rest but we don't know where it's going
to go Watergate was about a series of
crimes that there was evidence from the
beginning of that was quite clear about
the criminal acts and then it was a
question of well who committed these
criminal acts and it turned out
step-by-step that Richard Nixon the
President of the United States had
presided over this web of criminality
and the cover-up of the criminality
where we are now
is it's unclear what the criminality was
in the case of Watergate it was an
extraordinary attempt by the President
of the United States and those around
him to undermine the most important
element of our democracy and that is our
electoral process Nixon and knows under
him wanted to and succeeded to a large
extent determine who the nominee of the
Democratic Party for president of the
United States would be through a huge
campaign of political espionage and
sabotage of which the Watergate bugging
and break-in was a small part and the
object of this was to undermine the
strongest candidate for president in the
Democratic Party who Nixon thought would
be Senator muskie of Maine and to see
that the Democrats nominated the weakest
calm candidate who may have been a great
man but was a really weak candidate and
that was George McGovern and so you had
and then we in the press were able to
establish some ties that that Nixon had
indeed and those around and closest to
him had engineered this do you then have
a real investigation by 77 to nothing
vote or the Senate of the United States
a bipartisan investigation of the
campaign activities of the President of
the United States was undertaken you
couldn't get a 77 to nothing vote of the
Senate for anything today nor could you
have a legitimate bipartisan
investigation as we have seen that is
one of the big differences and one of
the other big differences between
Watergate and what we are witnessing now
is the response of the Republican Party
that the blind defense of this President
of the United States without regard to
the facts as they've been developed so
far by the Republicans in Congress
particularly is very different than what
occurred in Watergate real quick
that the Internet age is really
different in impatience and speed drives
it give it to us real quickly and you
talk to a reporter and I said when you
go out for an interview and he said oh
no I never go out for interviews
what that's that said oh I do it on the
internet or sometimes the wonderful
intimacy of the telephone and I you know
we're we we are not getting out and if I
do quick anecdote of working on the 4th
Bush book there was a general who
wouldn't talk and I wanted to and emails
intermediaries nothing so I found out
where he lived in the Washington area
and I thought ok I'm gonna go with outer
an appointment and this is the technique
I learned from Colonel you just show up
and I have a little technique of that it
somebody in the CIA once said let the
silence suck out but there was you and
so take this finger and stick it over
the little finger and jam it down into
the fingernail so it hurts and it is a
reminder to me to shut the [ __ ] off
[Laughter]
yes knock on the door in the first of
all you have to go at the right
strategic time you have to go about 8:15
on a Tuesday night after a drink
yeah we have after the generals had
dinner and so forth so he opens the door
and he looked at me he said are you
still doing this [ __ ] and I just did
this face and he looked and I just not
anything and he then gets a disappointed
look on his face I think not because of
what I did but because of what he was
about to do which was come on Ian said
for two hours and the answer goes to the
questions now why because somebody
showed up we're not showing up we're
sitting at our terminal and good point
writes
president Trump has reportedly discussed
not having a chief of staff what do two
former Chiefs of Staff have to say about
that I'll let you handle it well is
having a chief of staff absolutely
necessary with this president and let me
let me add to that if you could also
comment on the fact that there really
has been a great deal of turnover we've
had almost half of the staff turnover in
less than a year a lot of reasons for
that but give me your sense so why you
think that's happening okay well first
of all I President Trump was the chief
of staff when I was there I was chief of
stuff so
I was telling a lot jinho had certain
things I did the president is the chief
of staff is that he's the comms director
he you know Ford call it the spokes on
the wheel the idea that the president's
really in charge and he has these direct
reports coming to him and I think that
he's a person that likes to be involved
at every step of the way than the guy
that's going to be served dinner he's
gonna be the guy in the grill the guy
husking the corn he wants to be involved
in every thing going on and that
obviously begs the question as to
whether or not he actually needs a chief
except I think it's a legitimate
question and I know that's been debated
in the press and most traditional Chiefs
of Staff think that that's crazy and you
can't do that
but the reality is he's a person getting
to your second question that governs by
like I said before and I won't repeat it
all but he governs by allowing people
that agree with each other I'm very
little to get in front of him and argue
it out with the best egg game that they
can possibly have which then also causes
some of the articles that you read about
and some of the things that obviously I
had to deal with including as I said
earlier you know walking off that plane
and reading a tweet and heading back to
the west wing so I think that that kind
of drama is sort of part of the
decision-making process that he uses
traditional people don't like it but I
think again looking at the results that
is the process that will always be the
process it's not going to change and I
would argue that it works for this
president and it works for the promises
that he made to the American people it's
like it's likely that we're going to see
a lot of turnover in the White House
staff yeah I think you will and and you
know that's sort of why you know people
think you know
just earlier you know I've got this
attitude but you know don't you remember
what happened to you when you're in the
West Wing you know my the big that's
because that drama my drama whatever it
was doesn't matter to American history
and I believe the results of what he
does matters to American history alright
let's talk about the president now as
commander in chief and dealing with this
issue in North Korea how confident are
you are any of you that North Korea will
completely denuclearize and let me add
to that give me your sense of what a kim
jeong-hoon trump summit is likely to
produce now you know just based on my
own experience takes a look good
question for you to answer
yeah well but you know you have summits
you do a lot of preparation a lot of
work sometimes you you basically
negotiate on issues for a year or more
before the principles come in and get an
agreement just because this is a complex
issue this is about you know how do you
nuclear eyes how do you stop the missile
tests how do you do the inspections how
do you do the verification that needs to
be done along with the 100 other complex
issues so I guess the question is is is
he going to go into this thinking that
he's going to get a deal or is this
going to be a photo-op
or could this be a disaster well there's
some interesting there's partial answer
in the intelligence which is not which
is classified not public but in working
on this subject the intelligence
agencies tell the president that Kim
jong-un will not get rid of his nuclear
weapons for the obvious reasons
that's his leverage that's what got him
to the point he's at and what could be
given to him that would be some
legitimate trade off
and the reality is okay you get all the
US troops out of South Korea 35,000 when
you measure everything and maybe that
would be desirable but the United States
has a submarine fleet a aircraft carrier
fleet planes and so forth bases in Tokyo
yeah bases all over the place and so the
intelligence conclusion point recently
has been you'll never get him to give
this up because that's his weapon that's
what makes North Korea a major power
ergo what happens well but you see this
is the problem with people trying to
predict the future who knows there also
is one big unknown where I think this is
we don't know what's gonna happen in one
of those unknowns is until now as Bob is
saying that the existence of the North
Korean state like the existence of the
Pakistani state to some extent and some
other places is dependent on the
nuclearization question that really if
North Korea is a nuclear power his
belief you know of joining us is is that
there is a permanence to his state and
so one of the questions being debated
then Bob I think you can elaborate on
this by people in the intelligence
community well is there a possibility
that if somehow the South Koreans the
Chinese and the Americans guarantee in
some meaningful way the continued
existence of the North Korean state is
there a possibility that he then would
disarm but but we don't know the answer
is only a piece of paper
yeah and it
its value is the value of a piece of
paper and the new national security
advisor was on John Bolton was on
television this Sunday and he was saying
oh look at Libya is a wonderful example
they gave up their nuclear weapons
that's right Qaddafi is dead but the and
on this I think you have to be big
because what happened last year on North
Korean debate within the administration
after you left was hey look he Kim
jong-il
almost or maybe does have an ICBM with
the nuclear weapon on the top that could
reach the United States and the argument
to the president by the people who were
saying we've got to act was simply do
you want on your resume mr. president
that the most volatile regime in the
world got the capacity to strike the
United States with a nuclear weapon and
his hand what would be your answer no I
don't want okay
then what do you do and there are some
and president Trump has said this quite
openly there are some draconian options
that are draconian to this a little bit
of an aside from the day we walked in
the door before that President Obama met
with President Trump and told President
Trump very clearly and the president
would repeat this often in the Oval
Office that your number one issue is
North Korea and you should also be
assured that there is not a day that
goes by I think you all know that the
president has an intelligence briefing
everything
day with the intelligence community
there's not a day that goes by that
there isn't a portion of North Korea I
mean every single day there is learning
and teaching and things that go on okay
okay but I mean answer this question of
we in a few weeks late May early June
they're going to sit down for the life
of me I cannot imagine that they can cut
a deal in terms of the specifics of what
needs to be done
sure so what I anticipate is the best
scenario is that they meet they have a
broad agreement on a framework of what
possible issues you know some agreement
on Deedle kut'rs ation and agreement on
some other broad things but the
specifics of that are going to have to
be negotiated out I'm sure this is going
to take a while yeah exactly
president Trump is he's inclined you
know this very well well if there's some
if there's some positive he's gonna face
gonna proclaim a victory a won a Nobel
Prize yes maybe good and minute you know
and so maybe maybe peace in our time is
at hand
yeah if they make some old historical
metaphor
alright keep your fingers crossed folks
rights Priebus what facets of the
Republican political philosophy are
important to you and hasn't the
Republican Party principles changed with
Trump so the second part I'd say no I
think that President Trump is so unique
to himself I think that he is a person
larger than life I don't believe that
any of that is true that people debate
that you know the parties permanently
changed if anything I would say in some
cases changed for the better
I would say that we have opportunities
in this country when you look at
Michigan and Pennsylvania Wisconsin Iowa
by 10 points Ohio by 10 I think without
without the President and without I
think his brash in-your-face style some
of that wouldn't be reality but I also
don't believe that the that the that the
just like in Converse I don't believe
that the party benefits from the growth
that Trump has brought long-term just
like I don't think that the party is
injured by anything that you might
consider to be injurious to the party
because I think you Trump is so unique
to himself and to who he is that but
Republican but look the Republican Party
that I know the party of Reagan were for
less spending turn not more spending
they were for balancing the budget
well Reagan not huge dad - well I know
but it's the growth of government I mean
look and until the government if you
want less if you want less debt is that
the American public will have to decide
whether or not it wants to tackle
Medicaid
care Social Security there is no there
is no trajectory I'm not advocating it
I'm just telling you the numbers
there's no trajectory that can get us to
a place but we got a point we got a 20
trillion dollar zero how exactly are we
gonna deal with that resident I don't
disagree with you but you know when I
think about the party and I think about
opportunity I think about freedom and I
think about the choices that we have in
this country obviously every president
is gonna have their own stamp and their
own style of what that means but I but I
don't believe the platform I don't
believe the core principles have changed
at all but but the Republican Party was
for free trade well I think most people
in the party are for free trade but you
know what the president isn't lockstep
with every single piece of the platform
in the Republican Party just like Barack
Obama and Bill Clinton was not in
lockstep with every piece of the DNC
platform and I think that's what made
the president more competitive look we
had you guys know we had 16 people
running for president and you know I'm a
pretty traditional Republican I'm who
people called the establishment but I
don't believe that any one of the other
16 would have actually beaten Hillary
Clinton so while some of this stuff is
bizarre for people to listen to that
don't you know might be Democrat one of
doing - believe it he brought forward a
potpourri of beliefs some of which and
most of it came from the Republican
Party but some of those beliefs came
from President Trump and he put it
together he read the electorate and by
the way it's not just an American thing
that's happening in the UK it's
happening in France it's happening in
Italy it's happening all over the world
of people sick and tired of being lied
to
sold a bill of goods
nothing in return all right let me let
me let let me ask this question based I
mean kind of on where where the party is
now because we're looking at an election
in 2018 and predictions right now or
that you know Democrats are in a strong
position to take control of the house
perhaps take control of the Senate
let me ask all three of you what do you
think is going to happen in November of
2018 Carl I don't know
I think the demographics demographics
and what's going on now conventional
wisdom is that the Democrats will take
the house probably a better than even
chance that's the case I'm going to try
to frame the question a little bigger
and back to the theme of your Institute
here and that is about democracy working
this discussion and what's going on in
our politics is taking place in a
context in which our institutions of
democracy in this country are not
working and I never heard it expressed
more eloquently than rights did this
afternoon in with the stairs with the
students in an earlier session in which
he talked about some her soul that was
right in which he talked about the
single two structural elements that are
keeping our democratic processes in this
country from working gerrymandering
of districts ilat rights enunciated and
the electoral system itself which means
that really as you put it eight this
conclusion is different I've never heard
a Democratic Chairman expressed as
eloquently as you did this is not a
partisan manner and what you said is so
important I'm gonna lay it out ago but
we talked about a couple things earlier
today and one of the questions the
student asked was you know she felt like
your vote didn't count in California and
I
I don't disagree with her and you know
but the Electoral College is such that
when you run a national campaign when
you're chairman of the Republican
National Committee and you're the DNC
chairman
we're basically raising a billion
dollars each to be spent in seven states
we don't have there is no national
campaign for president it is like having
seven governors races in seven states
and us putting all the data all the
ground game everything we have in those
states to win that election and so that
is the electoral college that we have in
place and that's what we use but the
other the other piece of this was we
were talking about bipartisanship and
whether or not bipartisanship ship was
alive or dead I tend to be more cynical
and believed it's mostly dead and the
reason is is quite simple is that if
you're looking at state legislators or
House seats in the United States and you
know if Leon and I were best friends and
we had a beer together every night and
the porch and he were both in Congress
we got about 36 okay his district you go
that way and it's 80 percent Democrat my
district could go that when it's 80
percent Republican and we have no
incentive whatsoever to ever work
together because we'd lose and we would
never get anything done so that's the
short version we can talk more about it
later ladies and gentlemen you know
we're talking about obviously a divided
country at a time when we're facing a
tremendous amount of challenges and
challenges with regards to to leadership
I said to the students in a democracy we
govern either by leadership or crisis
what is needed today more than anything
is leadership political leadership that
is willing to take the risks associated
with leadership in order to deal with
the issues that we have discussed here
today and a lot of that leadership I
might say also rests with this audience
and your participation in our democracy
if you continue to participate in our
democracy I am confident that our
democracy will not only survive but it
will thrive in the future thank you very
much
[Applause]